nunca os habéis sentido extranjeros
extraños respecto a la gente que os
rodea a mí siempre me han pasado y sólo
encontraba la comprensión que me faltaba
en el arte así que desde pequeña tuve
claro que quería dedicarme a la creación
artística probé de todo pero no encontré
mi lenguaje natural hasta que empecé a
hacer fotos al principio hacía fotos a
mis amigos mi familia entonces mis
trabajos trataban de lo más cercano pero
con el tiempo lo cercano se queda corto
y quieres ir más allá descubrí así la
cultura asiática sus películas sus
libros sus fotografías
de asombrarme constantemente y descubrir
cosas nuevas me hizo feliz un día
haciendo fotos a un grupo de música
conocí usera
usera es un barrio de madrid conocido
como el chinatown madrileño a diferencia
de las zonas céntricas de madrid que
cada vez se parecen más al resto de
ciudades europeas usera me llamó
muchísimo la atención
digamos que usera es una especie de
pastilla entre distintas culturas
actividades y construcciones cuando
llega a mi casa me puse a investigar y
para mi sorpresa encontré un grupo de
facebook que se llamaba chinos de
segunda generación en españa si no lees
shawey el administrador de este grupo
decidió usar esta palabra para definirse
porque no se sentía ni español ni chino
pero a la vez las dos cosas y parte del
origen de este conflicto viene dado
porque para la gran mayoría de españoles
blancos los señores nunca serán del todo
españoles por el mero hecho de tener los
ojos rasgados me entró la fiebre china y
le comencé a hablar a todos mis amigos
del proyecto fue así como conocidas
ilusión
ciro es una artista china con la que mi
amigo jose coincidió en un taller de
danza en el reina sofía resultó que ciro
también estaba trabajando sobre la
comunidad china de españa pero desde la
performance y la danza
quedamos conectamos y comenzamos a
trabajar juntas mientras tanto y vamos
compartido intereses y nos dimos juntos
nos dimos cuenta que ambas nos gustaba
la misma música por ejemplo chavela
vargas las películas de wong kar wai
pasear es la filosofía de la naturaleza
y comer mucho dado que es muy importante
compartir la eficiencia comer mucho
con el tiempo me di cuenta de que son
los señores los que deben y pueden
hablar sobre sí mismos si así quieren y
que mi interés real estaban las
diferencias culturales que había entre
mi amiga y yo de la curiosidad que
teníamos cada una por el mundo de la
otra pasé a centrarme sólo en ciro mi
fascinación por ella no dejó de crecer y
hasta entonces he estado fotografiando
su crecimiento que ha ido de la mano del
mío
ciro nació en junio conocido en china
como la provincia en la que nació mao
tse tung y el occidente como el lugar en
que se rodó avatar pese a que comparte
país de origen con sus compatriotas el
70% de las personas chinas que viven en
españa y en europa en general provienen
de un lugar una provincia que se llama
acechan en esta provincia atrium
dialecto propio que ella no habla por lo
tanto no les entiende que sea esto para
la gran mayoría de europeos esta
comunidad representaba un país entero
aunque asilo se siente rara no será
solemos ir mucho allí a comer por las
comidas tan variadas que tienen tan
ricas y las mandarinas que siempre nos
ponen de postre las mandarinas siempre
han estado muy presente dentro de
nosotras y se han llegado a convertir en
una especie de juego a mí me recuerdan a
ciro y así los les recuerdan a los
olores de sus antiguas casas en junio
además en china en las mandarinas
simbolizan buena suerte y riqueza por
eso me gusta llevar siempre mandarinas
encima porque quiero pensar que con el
tiempo cada uno nos convertiremos en
propietarios de
nuestra suerte dueños de nuestra propia
suerte en este viaje por lo diferente
me he llegado a conocer a mí misma y lo
que me ha sorprendido más es que he
llegado a sentirme más reconocida que
nunca pero por dónde pasa este
reconocimiento pasa por el
descubrimiento de unas raíces de una
idiosincrasia para mí no para mí este
reconocimiento tiene que ver más más que
con las palabras tiene que ver con las
conexiones más que con los lugares tiene
que ver con los hogares
más que con en las lenguas tiene que ver
con el uso que hacemos del lenguaje por
ejemplo ser nombrados y escuchados y
sobre todo más que con definirse tiene
que ver con abrirse
y a menudo nos dice no encuentra tu
pasión pero yo creo que la clave no está
del todo ahí si bien es cierto que
llegamos a seguir tanteando descubriendo
lo que nos gusta creo que llegamos a ser
también preocupándonos por los demás por
las cosas y participando activamente en
la sociedad sintiendo que tenemos que
tenemos un lugar hace un par de años con
motivo del año nuevo chino me invitaron
a participar exponiendo las fotografías
que había hecho hasta entonces el año
nuevo chino que les había celebrado en
plaza espanya pero desde hace unos años
se celebra también en usera junto a la
comunidad china como propia organizadora
del evento y para la ocasión mi amigo
carlos garcía que también es fotógrafo
escribió un texto que me pareció muy
acertado en él decía que los tópicos son
lugares comunes promovidos por los
medios de comunicación de masas que nos
proporcionan respuestas simples a
problemas mucho más complejos a menudo
el papel de estos tópicos es disipar el
miedo sobre alguna novedad o cambio
y en otros momentos su papel es
promoverlo o incluso llegar a crearlo
estos tópicos se aprovechan de la
ignorancia de la sociedad para quedarse
ha vivido entre nosotros y legitimar el
poder para tomar decisiones sesgadas
además de esto
carlos decía también que en mis fotos no
hay no hay posición sino simplemente
vida y que como tal
hablan de aquellas epopeyas de siempre
aquellas europeas tras culturales que
podríamos pasar por llamarlo humana
en el mi viaje por la
por la imagen digamos que la imagen me
ha permitido a mí entrar en contacto con
una cultura lejana aprender e ir
destapando tópicos pero creo que no hay
que ahondar mucho para darnos cuenta de
que cualquiera de nosotros hemos sido
víctima alguna vez de los tópicos sea
por lo que sea y por lo tanto yo creo
que cada uno tenemos que coger esa
vulnerabilidad que tenemos ese
sufrimiento y usarlo desde el amor para
comprender a los demás porque todos
somos diferentes pero igual es el mismo
tiempo
quién eres a qué grupo pertenece es de
dónde vienes pueden ser preguntas
inevitables hoy en día pero puede que
sólo sean parches clasificaciones
simplificadoras para ocultar una verdad
mayor y es que todos somos uno y como
tal todos deberíamos ser tratados de la
misma manera creo que ojalá llegue el
día en el que las clasificaciones dejen
de ser necesarias para reivindicarnos o
para definirnos
hay una analogía preciosa en el libro
del tao de la ocde que dice que los
seres vivos cuando nacemos nacemos
blandos suaves y flexibles y al morir
quedamos duros rígidos e inflexibles así
quien sea suave y adaptable es un
discípulo de la vida y quien sea duro y
rígido es un discípulo de la muerte
seamos pues discípulos de la vida
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]